oh let's take a step back a node is any
device it fits onto a network right so
the topology is how those nodes fit
together
what kind of arrangement they're in
wreck now I told you this distinction
between the logical layer and the
physical layer okay and I said well when
we talk about topologies they're really
describing the logical layer how it how
it fits together and how it functions
right so let me just give you an example
now because you've got enough in your
head understands distinction a little
better if I said to you look I've got a
room okay like say this room and I've
got my nodes arranged physically around
the room like this right so like if you
walked into the room you know so here's
the room okay and here's here's the door
right then you walked in this is what
you would see okay so this is the
physical arrangement now the logical
arrangement the actual topology that it
is well what would you guess that it
would be what would you get exact oh you
get
a ring a ring is not a bad guess to make
if you had to get right doesn't look
like a ring so physically that's what it
looks like but logically uh well it
could be almost any of them right you
don't know which ones are connected to
it so for instance you might have this
guy connected to this guy and this one
to this one and this one to this one and
you might actually not have our one
network now you might even have like a
learning here who's not connected to
anyone
so this would be a series of
point-to-point networks yes or
alternatively you could have an actual
ring or you could have a double ring
with wires going in both directions or
you could have a bus you could have some
central medium that all of them have
access to or again there could be some
other node that you didn't actually see
when you walked in like say the one on
our ceiling at the moment one in the
middle and they're all connected to that
which would make this what kind of
topology a star right okay so I my
diagram is a mess now but hopefully
you're getting across the idea I'm
getting across the idea that physical
arrangement right versus logical
arrangement they're very different
things and usually the important thing
is logical how do these things function
here okay
now yesterday a couple of you asked me
well okay if this is what the six main
kinds of network topologies are um which
one which one are we using like which
one's happening in the school and which
one do I have a home what does it
actually look like in real life okay ah
and the short answer is none of them
none of them none of them okay let's
just try to revise our six for a second
okay what was the first one remote
simplest point Mikey okay and then when
we added more nodes to it we added a
central meeting they can access some
code on a bus right and then we we
looked at the ring over the last three
we sort of rushed through the star
because maybe one node is more important
than others then a tree or a
hierarchical one and the very last one
which we just skimmed over was
okay now um when you have a think about
these almost every network in real life
and especially you know an organization
with several hundred people in it like a
school um is not as simple as any of
these right even though it goes up in
complexity for instance in our school
physically speaking because there's lots
of separation between locations of rooms
and that kind of thing okay you've got
the library okay and there's a whole
bunch of our computers within the
library okay so if i zoom in to this i'm
you've got a whole bunch of servers up
there if you go inside the mrs. Ryan's
office it's another little cabinet that
is locked and there's no actually is one
screen but there's like eight computers
okay one screen for eight computers and
it's all air-conditioned is like two air
conditioning units in there because it
gets really hot so what you've got is
all of these servers they're all
connected to each other mostly okay so
what kind of topology is that it's a
match right but then these computers
connect to other computers outside the
library okay
so for instance in Cameron block okay
there's what we call a switch and also
computers access this all the computers
in Cameron blocks so that's the math
staff room and the HSA staff through and
any classes which have computer so
they're sort of connected here in this
kind of fashion so what kind of network
is that that's a star right and then I
can keep on going again actually right
here in this sub room here there's
another set of switches for the T block
right sorry T okay and again you've got
more computers feeding off here and I
haven't even started talking about the
wireless okay
so what kind of network is this is it
doesn't fit into any one of these very
neatly okay one of these is a variety of
these connected together so we would
call all of this is a hybrid
okay our hybrid Network now these two
ideas that something's logical but have
functions versus its physical
arrangement and this idea that many
different kinds of networks can be
connected together it's very very
important okay let me give you an
example what is this let me turn off the
lights YouTube what is this I'll admit
it's pretty old-fashioned I'm you've
probably never seen one before in real
life I've seen one in a museum well this
thing has a name what's it called what
what is this thing this this is called a
switchboard
switchboard okay so what would happen is
in the old days your phone right you
wouldn't necessarily know you've got a
phone number
I've got a phone number I finally got
you I'll just dial your number right you
would pick up the phone and someone
would pick up on the other end and they
would say operator right now - operator
is one of these people okay they're
sitting here and it's just hard to see
I'm going to show you a closer one in a
second with all these ports you can see
why is that a cutting out of it okay now
you'd Center the operator I'd like to
speak to and then you tell them and they
would do this they would arrange wires
on this switchboard right to connect you
to the person you want to speak to okay
so what's going on here how do we
describe this in network terms um what's
the topology that's that's happening
here hmm
yeah what what is it what is it well it
depends on how you think about it right
uh it depends on whether you're thinking
logically or physically logically
physically so I think logically how is
it functioning and when you're having a
phone call it today it works much the
same way as it worked then at least the
experience right there's you the source
of information and there's the person
you're talking to the destination how
many things are in between you when
you're talking to a child
logically there's no way between you
right it's not Chinese whispers you
speak and the other person hears
directly right what's happening is your
senior was going straight along that
wire to the other person okay so
logically what we perceive is a
point-to-point topology
okay point-to-point it's very simple
rent or else are involved in here but
physically what's actually going on
physically when I pick up the phone and
someone says operator right and you pick
up the phone and some of those operator
right we we're all you know our normal
plebs with phones at home we're all
connected to this thing right which is
some central location right where there
are several little you know incoming
connections so what kind of topology has
a central location that everyone's
plugged into it's a star right so
physically speaking now it's actually
closer to a star Richmond right so
you've got both of these happening at
the same time so it's tricky to keep
into your head
is there any questions about that that
okay all right
how are we done operate up because we
have operators it's just that they
aren't humans they're a piece of
software right which which is not that
confusing I mean calculators calculators
used to be people they used to be people
who'd have books with long tables in
them and when you wanted to do with
calculation you'd ask them say hey look
I have all of these calculations I need
to do for my business because I couldn't
do a council that kind of thing right
we've got calculators now we call them
spreadsheets right and they do it all
for us does that make sense so it's been
automated it's been all of this function
has been put into software okay and
instead of speaking to someone and
giving them verbal cues you punch up
this